Devonte Aaron
explicit today on Rogan we're going to
talk about spiders should you eat them
please come back you complete shit's big
is everything okay go back to bed can't
be losing sleep too does he take you to
big games he takes up less cap space
after a bad breakup can this perennial
Bachelor find a real catch the trick is
to find a generational talent and then
bury all the annoying parts of your
personality Kurt drive me around I'll
try the heart only gives blast inside
Rogers you look great what it can
receive
wrong route you stupid with Aaron
Rodgers what's your favorite part about
the Pro Bowl and uh Ellen lizard and
some guys I'm Sammy I don't know this
fall look things change I used to be a
punter and now I'm a media darling you
need to be open they need to be open
some misconnections
back so I can throw you anytime I want
make you wish you ran for it
God damn it God keep your eyes open
we're getting Devonte Adams
I'm just a quarterback standing in front
of a receiver asking him to take a
pickup for my sake
and most of all I hate the way these new
guys don't catch the ball not even a
little bit not even at all
I wish I knew how to quit you and the
Packers no just the Packers I mean
Jerry's been begging me to join the
Cowboys